welcome to engineering for reliability
with google cloud
hi
i'm ricardo developer advocating google
i work with customers of reliability
topics
in this episode we're going to explore
the art of slos and why it might be
useful for your organization
[Music]
wait what is art of slos
it's a workshop that will teach you how
to choose a slos for your workloads but
first what are sli and slos
well you might have heard about or even
read the sre books available for free on
sre.googleslashbox
here you find plenty of information on
how google operates reliable services
one of the main takeaways of that is
reliability is a key feature of your
service and that you should measure it
and set targets for it
at this point you might ask yourself
okay but how do i choose what
reliability target metrics and
thresholds are appropriate for my
application i mean you don't want to be
page every time a vm reboots right
you only want to be paged when you
believe that your service is not meeting
your user expectations
to get there you need a way to measure
your services ability to keep your users
happy and a way to set targets for
what's reliable enough
let's delve into it
an sli is a measure of how reliable
services for example if your service
provides an api you may choose latency
or availability but for a data
processing pipeline you may look more at
data freshness or throughput
an slo describes when a service is
reliable enough to meet user needs
an error budget is just a complement of
the slo so if your team chooses 99 as
reliability target the other budget will
be one percent that one percent is the
acceptable level of unreliability
you allocate the error budget to
maximize your development velocity while
maintaining the reliability of your
service
okay but what is the right target what
is enough
setting the right slow in practice is
really hard this is why we have created
a workshop to teach you we came up with
a simple online game played by millions
of users all over the world divided into
vampire clans we also have a leaderboard
to check if you're in the top 10.
there are plenty of business critical
user journeys login monetization battles
profiles leaderboard generation all
things your players care about
and how do you use this
each journey is a pragmatic and
self-contained exercise where you will
need to find what sli you care about
let's say latency
okay but latency between which two
points in time
you need to break your journey down to
the scope that you believe is most
important for your user
your team initially will disagree on
which is more important and the
discussion that will come up until you
reach consensus is crucial as you likely
trade off between business requirements
and engineering constraints
and now where do we measure it at the
load balancer or on the client app
your team will build up the muscles to
determine the right slos for your
journey and usually after two or three
iterations your team will get a lot
better at this
sounds good ricardo you may be thinking
but how much does it cost
nothing it's all freely available under
creative commons license you have slides
and docs for the facilitator who will
moderate the workshop and a participant
handbook that you can share with the
team
further the workshop has materials like
a retrospective exercise to refine an
existing slo
i hope i made you curious now feel free
to check it out and let us know what you
think
oh
sorry
sorry false i've just been paged we're
burning error budget for our latency slo
in a european region i need to fix this
a's up to ensure that we stay within our
slo
i knew i should have shot this video
while on call
wish me luck
[Music]
you